jacques delisle et le premier juge
canadien a croupi en prison pour une
condamnation de meurtre au premier degré
dans une entrevue exclusive à enquête
réalisée au pénitencier de
sainte-anne-des-plaines
il clame son innocence et donne pour la
première fois sa version des faits faut
que vous sachiez que je n'ai pas tué
nicolas il raconte comment il vit
l'humiliation sa condamnation même si
j'ai pas commis de près mais quand même
légalement je suis un criminel ce que
c'est quelque chose dont des enfants
sont fiers que d'avoir un père qui a été
reconnu criminellement responsables des
meurtres au premier degré mais mes
petits enfants
il se faisait à gacé l'école temps
grand-papa dessus est un grand moment
vous voulez vous supporter ça ça vous
affecte encore a oui la dernière chance
qui restent à l'ex juge de lille c'est
d'en appeler au ministre de la justice
des experts à qui nous avons subi la
preuve balistique endosse démarche
cette révision est nécessaire pour
écarter toute possibilité d'une erreur
judiciaire
pour la première fois la télévision les
enfants du juge delisle témoignent ses
engagements
ces heures ça pas de bon sens cette
journée là on a perdu notre mère qui ont
le coeur d'une autre par là on veut le
sauver
l'ultime recours à enquête jeudi soir
21h